nevers suivent et nous nous allons
retrouver denis thuriau qui arrive en
deuxième position lors de ce premier
tour derrière le maire sortant florent
sainte fare garnot c'est une bonne
surprise pour vous donner thuriau
bonsoir
oui bonsoir bien sûr c'est une bonne
surprise
j'entendais monsieur sainte fare garnot
nous expliquer que malgré mille voix de
moins eh bien il allait gagner la ville
de nevers pour la première fois en ce
qui le concerne ce qu'il n'a pas dit
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la les communistes
et les verts ce qui n'était déjà pas le
cas il y a 6 ans donc il n'aura aucun
report de voix ce qui va être très
compliqué et puis il y avait cette liste
et je note qu'un parti en place à nevers
le parti socialiste depuis 43 ans n'a
pas bénéficié justement de cet
éparpillement et de cette proposition
diverses voilà la situation telle
qu'elle se présente à nevers avec une
possibilité pour notre mouvement de
gagner le second tour